[Musique]
belmondo débuts dans le cinéma français
on n'avait jamais vu ça c'est la
nouveauté la surprise totale un physique
improbable de boxeur ce qui l'était
d'ailleurs dans la vie parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui était très sportif et il
jouait de façon phénoménale avec un
naturel une décontraction et puis un
côté émouvant et ce qui était bien c'est
que ça ne sentait jamais l'effort chez
lui et il a été complètement associés à
la nouvelle vague à cause de ça
puisqu'il ya eu à bout de souffle les
films de chabrol pierrot le fou et
c'était une révolution dans le cinéma où
tout était livre spontanée improvisé
dans la plupart des cas quand on
tournait plus en studio et lui qui avait
raté le conservatoire nature la fameuse
histoire de pierre dux qui leva et dit
avec le physique que vous avez vous ne
pourrez jamais tenir une jolie femme
dans vos bras et bien des années après
belmondo descendait les champs-elysées
avec ursula andress il tombe sur pierre
duluc c'est l'idée vous voyez on fait ce
qu'on peut
et semblait à personne au début c'est
pierre dux n'avait pas tout à fait tort
mais il n'avait pas saisi le talent de
duga dès le début non parce qu' il avait
effectivement une tête de boxeur mais un
charme inouï quand ils se mettaient à
sourire tout le monde font des hommes et
femmes et puis les femmes meurent et
sans doute envie de se retrouver dans un
lit avec lui et les hommes d'en faire
leur copain
ce qui était beau aussi chez lui c'était
le respect l'admiration qu'il avait pour
son père sculpteur ce qui prouve que ça
n'était pas seulement un comique
troupier mais qui savait ce que c'était
que là c'était quelqu'un qui disait
modiano et on n'imagine pas ça s'est il
y avait une certaine pudeur dans le
personnage qui n'est pas les passes à sa
culture et qu'ils préféraient se faire
passer pour un rouleur de mécaniques
avec ses copains qui lui tape sur
l'épaule et
combien vous ont proposé des souffles
il peut jouer un prêtre dans léon morin
il peut jeu pourra jouer le guignolo et
c'est assez rare d'avoir une palette
aussi vaste que ça et surtout tout à
l'air de sortir naturellement de lui
alors que ça devait quand même être un
clip plus ou moins à la base et il était
parfaitement accordé à as godard qui
improvisait fin qui improvisait qui
écrivaient les dialogues le matin sur
une table de café qui donnait le texte
aux acteurs et ça il n'y a pas beaucoup
de gens qui seraient capables de le
faire surtout aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
parce que aujourd'hui les acteurs ont un
physique un peu atypique mais je les
vois pas en train de jouer comme
belmondo qui respirait le celluloïd
comme si c'était son oxygène
alléguait le divin chauve
il a eu tous les tableaux lui la
nouvelle vague plus le succès public les
comédies populaires et c'était aussi un
acteur intellectuelle 1 comme on dit
parce que quand il est devenu producteur
il a produit alain resnais stavisky qui
s'est ramassé d'ailleurs et lci s'est
vraiment joué tous les rôles et c'est
quelqu'un qui peut jouer du marguerite
duras non moderato cantabile et puis
jouer dans le magnifique où il fait le
sigle est au complet et d'ailleurs c'est
sur ce film pendant le tournage au
mexique qu'il a fêté ses 40 ans et toute
l'équipe va saccager l'hôtel a jeté les
télévisions dans la piscine ça a été
vraiment le massacre et la patronne de
l'hôtel était tellement contente que
quand il a proposé de rembourser les
dégâts elle a dit non c'est offert par
la maison et le cinéma c'est ça c'est la
folie l'amusement noir et j'ai demandé
si friands
mais qui sont vieux copain charles
gérard qui disait de lui
jean-paul dans les scénarios il ne lit
que les cascades et effectivement c'est
rare de voir un acteur physique et qui
sait aussi jouer au théâtre c'est pas
c'est pas stallone a il sait tout faire
il peut monter sur un avion il peut être
pendu sous un hélicoptère ils peuvent
grimper sur le toit du métro c'est lui
qui fait ça on sent que c'était vraiment
un plaisir c'est ça qui est formidable
qui était formidable chez g belmondo
c'est que le plaisir était visible à
l'écran on sentait que pour lui c'était
une respiration naturelle et qu' il
pouvait passer là de son fauteuil où il
faisait des blagues à la scène
contourner
cette joie de vivre ça va avec le ca va
de pair avec le danger les cascades pour
lui c'était un amusement vraiment
c'était il l'aurait fait même s'il y
avait peu une caméra si hier on lui
avait prêté un avion pour grimper dessus
je suis sûr qu'il serait parti le
moindre aéro club et ça fait partie des
défis et de le cinéma c'est toujours un
prévu donc la prise peut être mauvaise
et une cascade peut être raté et on
reprend au fait ça et le risque est
toujours là et maintenant je vois plus
beaucoup de cascades dans le cinéma en
tout cas c'est toujours des doubleurs
sont occupés
[Musique]
les cascades c'était sans doute aussi
pour pour faire peur à ses parents
puisque quand il était gamin paraît-il
il escaladé la façade de son immeuble il
faisait tout un tas d'exploit improvisé
le risque qu'il aimait c'était son côté
sportif ça c'est en boxe on prend des
risques on reçoit des coups de poing et
puis c'est c'est le meilleur qui gagne
tandis que là les cascades c'était
vraiment son plaisir le plus sur le
tournage c'était un défi mail un combat
de boxe avec lui même et il ya des
reportages où on le voit descendre il
fameuse à lyon où il est debout sur les
ailes et on voit qu'il est enchanté 1 il
y avait ça souffle et il est prêt à leur
faire et c'est pour lui c'est une partie
de plaisir et aussi et se fait partie du
talent de comédien de savoir faire des
choses comme ça c'est qu'il n'y a pas
besoin de prendre une doublure sur le
métro si c'était pas allonger au dernier
moment avant que la rame entre dans le
tunnel et mourir est debout sur les
ailes d'un avion si vous casser la
figure c'est mal parti pour la suite de
votre avenir non monsieur je pense que
pour lui le cinéma c'est tel risque
en tant que producteur capteurs et puis
à la fin bon il s'est un peu laissé
aller amusé avec tous ces films en
blouson comment disent elles avec des
titres comme flic ou voyou le marginal
les morfalous mais on sentait qu'ils ne
prenaient pas ça au sérieux c'était pas
quelqu'un qui avait la grosse tête
jamais et on voit qu'ils estimaient que
c'était une chance inouïe d'être devenu
un d'abord un acteur ensuite une vedette
et de pouvoir faire ce qu'il voulait à
la fois à l'écran et dans la vie parce
qu'il a quand même eu les les plus
belles femmes du monde par dessus le
marché
des trucs là on n'aurait jamais avoir à
s'en servir
d'autant qu'on peut obtenir les choses
autrement
j'en suis sûr
tanner en demandant au début on disait
ce genre jean paul belmondo normalement
et puis tout d'un coup et ça a basculé
il est devenu bébel sans doute après
cartouche qui a été un énorme succès le
film de broca
la france a eu de la chance d'avoir à la
fois delon et belmondo en même temps là
pour les années 70 80 il y avait
plusieurs films par an ils ont même joué
ensemble ils sont engueulés plus ou
moins sûr borsalino à cause d'une
histoire de taille de noms sur la fiche
ils ont ils n'ont pas tellement
recommence et sauve dans un film de
l'eau courante à la fin une chance sur
deux mais il n'était pas tout à fait
dans le même registre mais ce qu'il y
avait de bien c'est que mine de rien il
jouait les flics qui jouait les voyous
mais chez les deux il y avait de
l'humour et avec belmondo et de long
s'était quand même quelque chose on a
plus idée de ce que c'était comme
énormité au cinéma les films faisait des
millions d'entrées c'était incroyable je
pense qu'ils s'estimaient et en plus
comme ils ne jouaient pas vraiment dans
la même catégorie c'est sans doute un
partage des tâches et de territoire pour
eux et ils avaient la chance d'être les
survivants d'un cinéma qui était
glorieux populaire connu dans le monde
entier et il fallait qu'ils se
différencient l'un de l'autre belmondo
c'était le côté marrant
décontracté en bras de chemise alors que
delon était plus le samouraï pour
reprendre un de ses titres mais ils ont
tous les deux une filmographie insensé
mais contrairement à belmondo delon est
passé complètement à côté de la nouvelle
vague parce que pour les réalisateurs
comme godard et truffaut j'imagine qu'à
ce moment-là il représentait le vieux
cinéma les les gens comme clément
melville et belmondo lui incarne la
nouvelle vague à lui tout seul ça a été
la révélation et il ya jean pierre léaud
et lui un pour la nouvelle vague
les français cultivent et se
souviendront de da bout de souffle et de
pierrot le fou et les
jeu français qui aiment le cinéma du
samedi soir se souviendront de du
guignolo de l'as des as ou de peur sur
la ville mais les deux sons sont très
très bien pour moi belmondo c'est dans
le magnifique le voisin de chaque ligne
bis c'est qu'ils rêvent sa vie en apport
à la machine est à voir au dessus une
fille comme hobby c'est c'est pour ça
que le cinéma continue et continuera à
faire rêver
[Musique]